[Música]
bienvenidos a esta entrevista exclusiva
en france 24
mientras la pandemia de 19 se sigue
extendiendo por el mundo por ahora la
única manera efectiva de contenerla es
adoptar medidas restrictivas o confinar
poblaciones ciudades o incluso países
enteros pero en las últimas dos semanas
ha habido destellos de esperanza frontal
primero por la alianza facer biotech y
luego por el grupo de biotecnología
moderna que anunció que su vacuna había
sido 94 5% eficaz en los ensayos
clínicos
estos dos desarrollos han despertado una
ola de optimismo a nivel mundial hoy
tengo el placer de darle la bienvenida a
france24 al cofundador y presidente de
moderno quien también es el director de
flash hay una gran nube afeite muchas
gracias por acompañarnos hoy desde
boston antes que nada cómo se siente al
saber que tiene la posible solución para
el mayor problema sanitario del mundo en
generaciones
muchas gracias por invitarme han sido 10
meses de intenso esfuerzo de un gran
equipo y simplemente estamos satisfechos
de poder contribuir y tener un impacto
en algo que representa un gran reto para
el planeta entero todo el mundo está
haciendo lo que puede en nuestro caso
somos un grupo de científicos ingenieros
y queríamos poner a disposición nuestra
tecnología que se ha desarrollado en los
últimos diez años para esta situación en
particular y nos alegra poder adelantar
la vacuna parecemos estar en un punto
donde tenemos una vacuna eficaz y segura
que ojalá pueda estar disponible para la
población
usted anuncio un 94,5 por ciento de
eficacia qué significa eso exactamente y
cómo llevaron a cabo sus ensayos
clínicos
nuestros ensayos clínicos comenzaron en
marzo dos meses después de haber
obtenido la secuencia del virus que era
un misterio en enero pasado pero el 11
de enero obtuvimos la secuencia a partir
de ese momento en dos cortos meses
pudimos diseñar el producto a ser el
producto probar el producto y tenerlo
listo para ser introducido en humanos la
primera fase de prueba involucraba
comprobar la seguridad del producto en
diferentes dosis es decir los diferentes
niveles de la vacuna de ahí empezamos
una segunda fase y eventualmente una
tercera fase en la tercera fase fue la
primera vez que pudimos saber si la
vacuna puede en realidad prevenir la
enfermedad y prevenir la enfermedad
grave lo que reportamos es que en el
estudio que involucró 30.000 voluntarios
sujetos divididos por partes iguales
entre el placebo es decir quienes no
recibieron la vacuna y la vacuna lo que
encontramos es que el primer inter
análisis de 295 casos de kobe 90 de esos
casos eran del gran grupo del placebo y
sólo 5 eran
de la balcones eso supone un 90 y 4.5
por ciento de eficacia y aún más
importante vimos que de los 11 casos
serios de ccoo bits todos los 11 estaban
en el grupo del placebo hasta ahora no
hemos visto ninguno en el grupo de la
vacuna esto seguirá y reuniremos más
información en las próximas semanas no
presentemos nuestro archivo para la
autorización que esperamos tener unos
150 casos pero esperamos que esos
números sigan mostrando resultados
similares y cuando tengamos el empaque y
la información de seguridad esperamos
poder seguir adelante y su vacuna
utiliza un nuevo método llamado a rn
mensajero ex podría explicarnos de
manera sencilla cómo funciona y por qué
cree que es el método correcto
y todo el que pueda recordar su primera
exposición en la biología sabrá que el
jugo básico de información biológica
dentro de nosotros es el adn que guarda
la información
las proteínas hacen mucho de lo que
tiene que ver con las células llevan a
cabo las funciones y entre el adn y las
proteínas hay una molécula llamada a rn
mensajeros que esencialmente es una
copia de cada una de las partes que
necesitan ser hechas en una célula para
cualquier situación de la rn mensajero
lleva la información desde el adn para
hacer una proteína no hay drogas o
vacunas que utilicen el arn mensajero
porque es un tipo de molécula con el que
ha sido difícil trabajar y que dentro
del cuerpo humano causa una reacción
inmune al sistema inmune no le gusta ver
esas moléculas se preguntan por qué
irónicamente es porque la rm es lo que
muchos virus utilizan para guardar su
información
de hecho el coronavirus el virus del
cobi 19 en realidad
el aire l para causar daño entonces
cuando una célula ve la rm por lo
general tratará de detenerlo a través
del sistema inmune lo que nosotros
descubrimos cómo hacerlo empezando hace
unos 10 años es proteger el aire los
modificar la rn y volverlo compatible
para hacer una droga y una vacuna
básicamente nuestra tecnología hace
posibles las moléculas aéreas esos
mensajeros para diferentes proteínas es
en este caso una proteína que causará
que el sistema inmune esté listo para
detectar y luego combatir el coronavirus
en particular damos esa instrucción y
ponemos el rn en una partícula
especialmente diseñada que puede
proteger de manera efectiva a la rn
hasta que ingrese a la célula toda esta
tecnología se desarrolló durante los
últimos 10 años hemos gastado unos dos
mil y medio millones de dólares y
actualmente estamos en un punto donde ya
se han probado 10 vacunas diferentes
modernas en los últimos cinco años
se está trabajando en otros 10 programas
sobre cáncer enfermedades
cardiovasculares enfermedades raras todo
eso este año nos puso en una muy buena
posición para aplicar esta tecnología
usted pregunta por qué es el mejor
método no podría decir que es el mejor
método creo que es el método más rápido
y tiene ventajas sobre otros métodos
pero le damos la bienvenida a todas las
vacunas que puedan proteger a los seres
humanos lo que vamos a necesitar miles
de millones de dosis esperamos que
muchas personas tengan éxito en esta
travesía
hoy tienen muy buenos resultados pero
como pueden estar seguros de que esta
vacuna será efectiva a mediano y largo
plazo
cuando se enfrenta a un virus que no se
ha visto antes lo que se puede hacer es
aprender de otros virus similares y
stevie de usarse en particular tiene de
cierta manera primos previos que han
ingresado a los humanos a partir de ahí
tenemos una idea pero realmente no se
sabe lo que hay que hacer es llevar a
cabo investigaciones médicas monitorear
a los pacientes monitorear a las
personas que fueron vacunadas y ver si
es posible crear una evidencia de que la
protección va a durar ojalá seis meses
un año tal vez tres años tal vez cinco
años porque simplemente no lo sabemos
pero claro lo único peor que no saber
cuánto va a durar en no poder
protegernos a nosotros mismos
en este caso sacaremos adelante la
vacuna protegeremos a las personas y
observar si la protección empieza a
desvanecerse y vemos más casos en la
franja de la vacuna podemos estimular la
vacuna y volver a inyectar la en el caso
de la tecnología aérea en el mensajero y
eso es un poco diferente a las demás
podemos aplicar vacunas adicionales y
podríamos ayudar
personas todo esto se resolverá en los
próximos meses y años no para fechas y
qué pasará si el virus muta
es posible modificar o actualizar su
tipo de vacuna
sí pero permítanme contestar en dos
partes primero el virus puede mostrar de
repente siempre y cuando la proteína ese
que creamos en nuestra vacuna no cambie
materialmente eso no tendrá ningún
efecto en la capacidad de nuestro
sistema inmune para detectarla imaginen
una pelota de fútbol por ejemplo en la
que cambia una pieza suponiendo que esa
pieza no es la única porción de
información o intervención lo demás que
queda puede informarle al sistema inmune
que siga atacando de todas maneras pero
si resulta que las mutaciones es tan
grande que afecta a la proteína ese que
utilizamos en ese caso la tecnología rnp
mensajero puede aplicarse rápidamente
con otro código molecular
ahí está la belleza de este método que
desarrollamos porque así como nos tomó
días poder tomar la secuencia y hasta
nuestro primer mensajero pensamos que de
ser necesario si las mutaciones son
demasiado grandes claro que podemos
desarrollar otra molécula
y ponerla en el mismo empaque hacer todo
igual probarla y luego poder sacarla
adelante como otra vacuna de nuevo
esperamos no tener que hacerlo pero
estamos listos para hacerlo
y probablemente muchas de las personas
que nos están viendo están preocupadas
por qué moderna ha tenido éxito en
alcanzar esta fase final muy rápido que
les diría para asegurarles que su vacuna
es segura
cuando se realiza este tipo de trabajo
lo que hay que hacer es seguir las
pautas que se han establecido con base
en décadas de desarrollo de vacunas
puedo decirles que nosotros fighter iv
todas las empresas que se que están
haciendo esto al menos las grandes han
seguido las mejores prácticas los marcos
regulatorios que existen eso es lo mejor
que podemos hacer se puede trabajar con
un amplio número de personas lo cual
hicimos en nuestro estudio 30.000
voluntarios y eso continuará se puede
continuar incluso una vez que salga la
vacuna observando de manera vigilante y
atenta a los resultados y el desempeño
de la vacuna eso es lo mejor que se
puede hacer creo que cualquier vacuna o
droga que cualquier persona utilice
demuestra ser segura con base en el
desarrollo de los ensayos clínicos que
se realizan y nosotros lo hemos hecho
por ir rápido no nos hemos saltado en
ningún paso y el rigor lo contrario en
realidad por ser una pandemia ha habido
cientos de ojos sobre este programa
examinando
hemos tenido colaboraciones que van
desde el vih y ahí de barba en eeuu
muchos consultores científicos clínicos
diversos lo mejor que podemos hacer es
hacer las cosas rápido pero de manera
minuciosa y eso es lo que hemos hecho
cuando espera que su vacuna esté
ampliamente disponible
efe
lo primero es solicitar una autorización
de emergencia de primer uso que
permitirá que los trabajadores médicos
de primera línea unas poblaciones
altamente vulnerables tal vez de la
tercera edad reciban las primeras
distribuciones de la vacuna que
esperamos en nuestro caso empiecen en
diciembre en todo caso antes del final
de año
después de eso aumentaremos nuestro
volumen y solicitaremos una licencia
biológica completa que esperamos en el
primer cuatrimestre al obtenerla habrá
más disponibilidad lo que será un
limitante es el suministro ahora si las
dos primeras vacunas son las únicas en
estar disponibles en ese momento tomará
un poco de tiempo mientras aumentamos la
producción para poder distribuirla con
mayor amplitud pero espero que haya otra
vacuna disponible para mediados del
próximo año y que la carga se reparta
entre varios métodos
dijimos que haríamos entre 500 millones
y mil millones de dosis para el próximo
año y varios otros dieron cifras
similares
algunos incluso mayores esperamos que
entre todos esos métodos podamos tener
una cobertura adecuada para poder
vacunar en 2021 la mayor cantidad de
población que se quiere abandonar cuál
será el precio de la vacuna de moderno
como no estamos vendiendo el producto en
términos comerciales y solo se le está
vendiendo a los gobiernos cada uno de
los contratos que tenemos fue negociado
de manera separada con base en los
volúmenes y con base en una lógica
estándar para ser equitativos de manera
global por ejemplo estamos trabajando
con kóvacs en los países en desarrollo
para poder seguir los lineamientos de
precios de los países de ingresos bajos
con eeuu como se ha reconocido de manera
pública tenemos un contrato para las
primeras 100 millones de dosis esto se
determinó con base en el hecho de que el
gobierno de eeuu también proporcionó
capital de desarrollo en cada caso es un
poco diferente pero se está realizando
de manera abierta y todo el mundo está
haciendo lo mismo
para facer en este momento su principal
rival es la alianza facer bien pero dado
que la demanda de la vacuna será inmensa
a nivel mundial con seguridad del
mercado es lo suficientemente grande
para muchos proveedores diferentes hay
espacio para todos en él
absolutamente como lo dije le damos la
bienvenida a una segunda tercera cuarta
quinta creo que el mundo necesita que se
atienda a este problema y sin duda hay
10 vacunas diferentes que ya están
bastante avanzadas esperamos que tengan
éxito de hecho con el tiempo estas
vacunas tendrán distintos desempeño
tendrán una cierta diferencia en la
eficacia cierta diferencia en la
seguridad cierta diferencia en la
durabilidad
por ejemplo en nuestro caso en cuanto a
la cadena de suministro las condiciones
de refrigeración para el almacenamiento
tienen ciertas ventajas porque no
necesitamos llegar hasta los 70 grados
bajos cero de congelamiento invertimos
años de trabajo en asegurar que nuestro
proceso nos dé un producto estable a 20
grados bajo cero
pero también reportamos esta semana una
segunda noticia esta semana hubo dos
noticias y la segunda fue que
demostramos estabilidad de nuestra
vacuna hasta por 30 días en un
refrigerador eso quiere decir que puede
estar en un
a 20 grados bajo cero en general y luego
cuando se usa se puede conservar en un
refrigerador 30 días y 12 horas en una
mesa a temperatura ambiente todo esto
puede parecer trivial pero afecta
drásticamente el uso y la disponibilidad
general cada uno de los desarrolladores
de la vacuna está haciendo su mejor
esfuerzo para que el producto tenga la
mayor efectividad luz sol ya cima pero
moderna es pionera de la tecnología a rn
mensajero muchas de sus innovaciones
están siendo utilizadas por todo el
mundo para poder llevar a cabo sus
vacunas a rn mensajeros tales habrá
visto que hace dos meses anunciamos de
manera voluntaria que no le impondría
mos las patentes de la empresa a los
demás durante la pandemia porque nos
dimos cuenta de que otros también
necesitan desarrollar la vacuna de
manera segura y eso es lo que estamos
promoviendo
rápidamente es optimista frente al nuevo
futuro futuro
si me conociera sabría que soy optimista
en cualquier situación entonces mi
optimismo no está en función de los
datos diría que estoy motivado estoy
extremadamente aliviado estoy agradecido
con el equipo que ha trabajado en
moderna día y noche durante los últimos
11 meses para poder producir a toda
velocidad y estoy a la expectativa del
impacto que tendrá su trabajo no sólo en
eeuu sino en el mundo entero
soy naturalmente optimista y no tengo
razón para no serlo
ese es todo el tiempo que tenemos muchas
gracias por hablar hoy con nosotros no
era face cofundador y presidente de
modelo y muchas gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos quédense con nosotros aquí
en france 24
[Música]